ich muss jetzt anhand des ohres erraten
welcher youtuber das ist hallo mein name
ist luca und ich darf euch heute hier
ganz ganz herzlich begrüßen zu einer
folge von erkennst du diesen youtuber
warum zu einer folge ist keine serie
hier auf jeden fall sieht er hier vorne
schon einen screen eingeblendet und
jetzt müssen wir sagen welcher youtuber
das ist das ist ja ganz easy wir können
jetzt einfach auf irgendeiner stelle
hier draufklicken ich klicke jetzt
einfach mal direkt in die mitte und
ich würde sagen das ist der minecraft
skin von piloten ohne jetzt irgendwie
mehr davon frei legen zu wollen wenn ich
mich jetzt mal ganz weit aus dem fenster
und ja zehn habe ich jetzt bekommen ein
paar sekunden später
ja geil kein netz kein problem
das hier ist der nächste youtuber mehr
anhand der buchstaben und kann ich jetzt
noch nicht genau sagen wer das sein
könnte allerdings klinge ich jetzt mal
einfach hier drauf das speed
oder ich weiß nicht ob ich jetzt auf
alle hier drauf
das pci e tsmc so tietz nie so
fortfahren machen wir das nächste anhand
der buchstaben kann ich wieder nicht
erraten allerdings in germany this place
ist das easy oder bin ich geil lerman
let's play auch richtig jeder buchstabe
war drin
dann klicken wir jetzt mal hier drauf
das ist samt endo meine ich soweit ich
das richtig erraten kann wir können uns
ja selbst an die stellen stellen dass
ich das anhand eines ersten aufgedeckten
bildes erraten muss contento hier
natürlich auch richtig für uns einige
bewertung bitte später mitglied im board
von oh mein gott dieser schon wieder
höher dinosaurs egal wo du bist mensch
freunde das ist kein werbevideo für
diese aber oh mein gott wie vorhin
gesagt haben wir jetzt gerade die
challenge am laufen das nicht nur ein
kärtchen aufdecken darf also ich klicke
jetzt einfach mal direkt in die mitte
und würde sagen dass das krank ist weil
das ja auch seine skin oder seinen also
halt er selbst quasi nachgestellt ist in
comics gezeichnet genau gong fortfahren
das nächste würde ich sagen das kgb
genau vor
das nächste ich versuche es jetzt mal
nur anhand der buchstaben hier ausfindig
zu machen also wir sehen erst sechs
buchstaben und dann drei buchstaben
er ist das sogar dass ich irgendwas
aufdecke aber gar die salami hier würde
ich sagen teilen des jeweils zweimal
fünf buchstaben und die wörter verraten
dass auch schon so ein bisschen also
simon desue genau fortfahren
dann haben wir hier sechs buchstaben da
was könnte man den bauer
why did i wir ändern die challenge um
freunde ich muss den youtuber erraten
ohne ein einziges bild also hier ist es
jetzt relativ schwierig anhand der
buchstaben wir sind ja auch schon im
level 10 jetzt angekommen ich klicke
jetzt trotzdem man auf die mitte
damit ich weiß wer das ist und ich
glaube alles ist das ok floyd ich weiß
nicht ob man für jedes aufgedeckte dings
irgendwie was bezahlen muss oder so weil
irgendwie oder kann man nur eine gewisse
anzahl aufdecken man kann theoretisch
man kann man kann ja so viel kann man
auf decken hier ist es ebenfalls relativ
schwierig und zwar mit sieben buchstaben
habe ich denke jetzt einfach in die
mitte das ist
wie heißt denn sein
typ kanal nochmal juli yankow genau den
haben wir hier klicken wir fortfahren
auch mal wieder direkt in die mitte das
ist kommt noch ein
a
also ja es kommt hier mit dem buchstaben
und ein und das ist jetzt auch richtig
aber ich wusste nicht dass das victor's
youtube bild ist wir klicken hier jetzt
mal einfach oben rechts sind da kann ich
noch nicht erraten runden rechts kann
ich auch noch nicht erraten unten links
oben links auch nicht und direkt in die
mitte zara zara
wird ein bisschen schwieriger hier schon
oh mein gott ich liebe diese app zum
glück haben sie dafür noch einmal
werbung gemacht auch geil da gehe ich
hier wieder in die app reinery sie
direkt die nächste werbung für irgendein
anderes spiel wonach an gerade versucht
linien zu verbinden so wurden ein geiles
spiel es super klicke ich jetzt drauf
weil klick aufs kreuz und kommt trotzdem
im app store ich klicke jetzt einfach
wieder straight in die mitte jetzt hier
jetzt hier ist es im rat dann machen wir
natürlich gmbh ist auch richtig
fortfahren freunde ab jetzt darf ich nur
noch ein kärtchen aufdecken und wenn ich
mehr aufdecken muss habe ich jetzt
verloren und das videos vorbei also
anhand der buchstaben kann ich hier
nicht so wirklich erwarten nämlich
klicke jetzt nicht direkt in die mitte
sondern hier hin
ich muss jetzt anhand des ohres erraten
welcher youtuber das ist ich würde sagen
abo also a dann haben wir hier vorne das
pd genaues richtig fortfahren und fauna
amazon werbung dass jetzt der nächste
youtuber wir haben neun buchstaben ich
gehe jetzt erstmal direkt das erwarte
ich nicht wie soll ich
drillisch hat gerade kurz überlegt dass
es casey leistet ist mit der brille aber
freunde ich würde sagen an der stelle
kann ich nicht weiter raten ich mache
jetzt mal hier drumrum jahres revue aber
ich hab es nicht hingekriegt
das war allerdings vor dem 1
hey wie gehts das war sich auch von dem
video meine damen und herren wenn es
euch gefallen hat und eventuell solche
youtuber erraten quizzes apps öfter auf
einem kanal sehen wollte er das gerne
mal ein leichter ich war nicht drin
[Musik]